Weekends are meant for relaxing and rejuvenating,
but it's easy to forget that when we're swamped
with never-ending homework, college applications
and demanding jobs that have us working overtime.
Consequently, plans that we originally signed
up for might seem like a hassle now.
It's perfectly okay to stay in, hit the pause
button and catch your breath.
In fact, I’m about to do that myself, so
sit back, relax and come unwind with me, it'll
all be okay, I promise.
Today is my lazy day, with no plans in sight,
I’m starting off with a blank canvas which
means I can paint the day however the way
I want it to be.
Let's check the weather, seems like it's cloudy
and windy, my favorite sweater weather.
I'm going to go downstairs, greet my cat and
brew myself a hot cup of tea.
Whether you enjoy something calming and herbal
or strongly caffeinated, your boy's got you
covered, I’m loaded with the good stuff.
Now on to laundry, sounds like work, right?
But doing laundry after a long week can actually
be rewarding, I love burying myself with the
scent of fresh clean clothes.
Now that I have something to wear next week,
there's one less thing I have to worry about.
Here, I’m gonna get the first batch started
and then we'll move on to something else.
I'm really lucky to live in a quiet area surrounded
by woods.
Today, I think I’ll go for a bike ride.
I've got my favorite cardigan on and a scarf
to keep my neck warm.
Sometimes nature is the only friend you need.
As much as I love spending time with my friends
and family, I love going off by myself and
having my own solitary adventures.
With life these days, it's often quite hard
to get some peace and quiet, so when I have
the chance, I make the most of it.
I've been thinking lately about how much I’ve
let my own anxiety and depression dictate
my life, how its taught me cold from taking
certain risks, postpone the time I could have
used to work on personal goals and the way
it would keep me up all night.
It doesn't have to be that way anymore if
I just learn to let go.
If you're going through the same emotions,
I hope you have the guts to do it too.
Ahh, wasn't that fun?
It felt so good to let the crisp cool air
into my lungs.
And the way the leaves fell, it looked like
small bits of a kaleidoscope rearranging its
patterns.
That's what I love the most about fall; you
can heal and learn to become what you can
still be.
Just because everything breaks down in this
time of the year, it doesn't mean good things
have to come to an end.
Sometimes change happens so better things
can fall into place but we have to be open
to receive it.
I like to think that with every end comes
a new beginning.
Come inside now, your ears are getting cold,
aren't they?
Let's go back to the kitchen and cook ourselves
a nice dinner, you'll have to excuse me, I
haven't gone grocery shopping yet.
Let's see what's available in the pantry.
Hmm, a can of tomato sauce and some angel
hair, looks like we're having spaghetti.
Sometimes dinner is the best when it's prepared
simple.
I'm just gonna chop up an onion and throw
in some spinach.
Fall makes me nostalgic for my mom's cooking.
In fact, I learned how to make this dish from
her, mmmh, some things never get old.
Dinner is always better with some company.
Now let's end that night with a hot relaxing
bath.
There's nothing like lighting your favorite
scented candles and sitting with a good book
and music.
If you live in the city, it can almost be
impossible to slow down when everyone's always
rushing to get to the next stop, but when
you're in a bathtub, you're safe, warm and
away from all the noise.
Whatever scent you picked up from riding the
train or being at school, you can leave all
of that behind you as you soak in these bubbles.
Ahh, looks like it's time for bed now, my
cat knows it too; she's been waiting for me.
I love the way she snuggles up close to me.
Another day has come to an end but it was
everything I needed.
Are you feeling better now?
Keep these tips in mind the next time you're
all wound up.
What other relaxing techniques do you use?
Unlike the scriptwriter Catherine, I myself
really like playing video games too online.
What about you?
Let me know by leaving a comment down below.
Be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
content.
Thanks for watching.
Hi everyone, as you may have noticed, we don't
post as often as we'd like anymore.
We are low on funding as our expenses are
exceeding our revenue.
However, we want to keep making more content
that help people learn about psychology and
mental health.
So we want you to be a part of that process.
Starting today, we will have a donate button
underneath our videos.
You've probably seen it in some of your favorite
channels already but if you don't see the
button, we've included a link in the video
description.
Our vision is to keep making psychology more
accessible to everyone.
We try to keep our videos concise and create
open dialogues among the community.
As a supporter, you will receive recognition
for your support by having a cool site icon
next to your username when you comment.
This helps us recognize it's you and engage
you more.
On top of this, you will also receive a free
copy of our Psych2Go eBook and occasional
magazines every quarter.
Just email in to myself when you've donated
and I will send you the copies at tia@psych2go.net.
However, even if you cannot support us financially,
we still totally understand, you can help
us out by sharing this video; we still love
you and will give you a free eBook if you
mail in to let us know.
There is no fixed term or shady things like
that; you can also cancel your support at
any time too, so there's absolutely no risk.
We promise to use your funding wisely and
for creating new videos that can help others.
Let's make psychology more accessible for
everyone.